[Music]
moonlight
i knew it was special
a hundred percent and nothing that
happened really surprised me to be way
honest with you meaning if i was if i
really think about being in the moment
moment to moment from reading the script
to
the casting process
to starting the film in the couple of
days we i filmed you know i worked on it
like maybe six or seven days naomi
worked on it like three to seeing the
first cut of the film to the the the
festival circuit
the growing
response to the film it was such a
humbling thing to be a part of but being
in the midst of that of all those
amazing energies and that much talent
i wasn't i wasn't necessarily shocked by
the all the things that happened from it
but it was just
experiencing it in real time
was fascinating how do i know
just do
i think
you know you know
hey
you gotta know right now
all right
not yet
do so drugs
she do drugs right
it was the first script that i've ever
read that had moved me to tears like
that by the time i got to the end of it
clearly was something i'd never seen
before and the fact that it was all
these
beautiful black characters
filling this story up it was
it was just amazing it was amazing it
was unprecedented this story is so
beautiful the script was so beautiful
the character was so
well drafted and and
and built out that it it i want i don't
want to say it was easy to step into
those shoes but barry and terrell made
the job very manageable from from the
work that they did in in building that
character i think the main thing with
juan was just recognizing that he lived
in the heart space
no matter what was going sort of on in
his life or his occupation and what have
you like that was sort of the least
important thing it was
who was he at his essence you know and
he was somebody who could
who could recognize when someone needed
help
and
just embraced a young boy
you know from the standpoint of somebody
who who could recognize that somebody
needed help so that means i think
you just have to understand somebody who
walked on the world with empathy
and so i i just tried to
honor that character by having as much
empathy and
positivity and awareness and love
as i could
possibly manage to bring forth
to connect with little
[Music]
[Music]
you're not distracted
by the motion and the movement and the
camera and all the technology around if
anything
at least for me i was very aware of
the importance of us getting these
things right it's like you can't permit
it to be a distraction that's the only
way i can and you gotta actually work
with it
and you gotta understand that everybody
is all of this exists so that we can all
tell the story i think the gift in this
in this work is that it requires
so much attention and concentration all
that motion and movement and
stuff that's happening
at times it can actually be helpful in
terms of you really connecting to
what you're doing why you're there and
helping you stay focused is
because you don't want to lose it so
desperately you know but james lackson
was the dp on um
um moonlight and i i think working with
somebody like that who has that type of
energy and that type of the type of
respect he has for actors is paramount
and so getting to work with him becomes
a little bit of a dance doing my part to
make sure that he was able to do his job
so that we could tell this story i just
feel like that movie was a was made for
the right reasons and about the right
things so i just feel really honored to
have
had a small part to play in that you
know because a lot there's a world of
people that contributed to that movie
being what it is no more important than
barry jenkins and twirl album mccraney
i'm glad we
were and humbled that we were able to
to collectively execute
in order to connect with people
[Music]
green book
you know at that time i remember asking
a lot of questions and and trying to
find
my in
and it was kind of like well this is
kind of all we have on them like there's
a lot of music
um but not a lot of information right i
was like all right well this is what i
have to go off of i saw that we were
really
significantly different physically and i
just tried to understand where his
energy was coming from where did where
did he move from what's his body
language it told me what i saw i could
tell he's very proud you know the way he
articulated and enunciated like told me
something like just so i had to use all
those things as
it's like you take a tincture or
something which is like something
distilled down from something really
larger right and
so all you can what you can do is like
okay there's the essence of someone
there i'm not gonna
be able to
be him per se but out of what i have
i understand where certain things are
coming from and i can use those little
pieces at a certain point i felt like i
had
a character with some dimension i just
it's just a feeling it's like
are you in love i
think so yeah i feel it like you just do
you know like i think you know it's true
when you when you sort of collectively
feel it you either feel great or you
feel conflicted
going home after work like usually when
you have to worry about the technical
aspect of it how does that work
that was the toughest part of making
that film because the musical pieces
would be changing all the time and it
was like okay we're gonna do this piece
well actually we're gonna do this other
piece
so
i would be watching chris and making
sure i was in the right place
you know and we just figured out how to
do it but again it was really abstract
trying to get down
to the truth where this is what pete is
going to end up using is
that part right so you're having to be
conscious of
don shirley's
trajectory
in the movie
related to where he's at
in the concerts what moment just
happened and how this how should this
concert feel
considering
they just left this thing and he got
beat up or something like that so what
are what is this one how is this how's
playing this song gonna feel different
from you playing the song at the
christmas party like a couple or
whatever the the little event a few
scenes earlier right because once you
start getting into some of these
technical pieces you can lose track
of the fact that you also have to
carry all the information all the
experiences that have happened up into
that moment so you got to make sure that
you're acting while you're playing and
so just to be aware of that you know was
was the challenge with that but
chris was amazing to work with he's the
only reason i was able to pull that part
off that was my first
opportunity after moonlight the
moonlight was really a miracle right
like
it
to go from you know working on something
for seven days to
you know hair is a huge opportunity and
it's kind of just you and viggo
mortensen you're like what
you know and so i feel very grateful
for for that opportunity and for all the
good that came out of it
um and for all the things that were
difficult about
i feel really grateful to have embraced
those lessons but also have navigated it
and sort of survived it because there's
just so much i wasn't aware of prepared
for
so it was a lot of
difficult lessons it's like a real real
education but i'm happy i'm happy about
the challenge i'm happy about getting to
embrace an extraordinary character
because what i love about dr shirley was
and i still feel this way
he was somebody that we had never seen
before like that
that even and even though my iteration
of dr shirley wasn't
the actual dr shirley right you do the
best you can within the information that
you have but if you think about a
character who was empowered in the 60s
who flipped off the south by having a
white driver like that was gangster like
to go like oh i had this white guy
driving me around
through the south carrying my bags in
1961 62
and getting out and also you have to
protect me like any other
guy would at that time working for him
was crazy and
just the way he navigated situations
his intellect his overall just ability
heart and warmth i felt like oh this is
this is a new contribution to the canon
and wow i get to do that
cool i'm grateful for that
true detective
oh man nick pizzellato man good dude
nick i met with them originally pitched
me on on what would eventually be the
stephen dwarf character but i was like
yo i really want to play this league cop
man i i really do i'ma just be honest
with you i've been supporting for
18 years at that point i was like yo i
just need a different experience like
for real
and
let me send you this these pic let me
send you something so i got these
pictures of my grandfather who was
a military officer naval officer and
then eventually a california state
police officer back in like the 60s 70s
and i sent him a few pictures
that
pretty great very stoic beautiful man
and i sent them those pictures because
the story originally took place in 1979
and once we started filming they changed
it to 80 right but there was something
about the 70 part of it 79 that i felt
like to to ask
or try to engage
in in the conversation of like playing
this league cop i felt like i needed to
support that with
a real picture some real pictures and
say that we existed in that time and
that there there was some degree
of presence and empowerment because here
it is my grandfather's a california
state police officer
so i sent him
those pictures he was like whoa okay and
i think my
pitching myself i was
i was
pretty passionate about feeling like i
could do it and really wanted that
that challenge you know and
hats off to him he was like yeah man all
right let's do it and i think sometimes
like writers get afraid because they
feel like oh if i have a black guy in
the lead and i'm not a black guy or i'm
not a or whatever i have to suddenly
incorporate all these like
racial elements in it and i have to make
sure i get them right and like
you do and you don't and i just was
really trying to pitch him on the fact
that it was not like you have to change
the script significantly but i just
think you have to have a real awareness
about how subtle
our differences are how subtle the
racism can be how subtle the
discrimination could be and i would give
them an example like it doesn't mean
like the guy has to be like hey n word
you ain't supposed to be up in here
right or whatever it could just be i'm
standing there with rolling it's wayne
and rolling i'm playing wayne and the
guy just assumes roland stephen dorf's
character is must be the cop in charge
because he's the white guy so he don't
even look at me he shakes his hand and
it's like addressing what happens with
him i was like it's subtle like that
that is often how
folks experience racism is that you you
feel it on these on
sort of the micro levels and so that was
the conversation about how to
incorporate some of these things in by
making me that character i remember one
of the the main thing that we were going
to focus on focus on was at least for
the age age whatever like 35 compared to
age maybe like age 33 compared to age
like 43 or something like that was just
the hairstyles and so since the first
part of the story was like 1980 right
we were really talking a little bit
about aversion somewhere between like
this military flat top jerry curl type
thing like something that felt in that
world to go in
to a more
box cut by the time you you know advance
a few years ahead you know and so the
hair
the hair was something that i felt like
would really tell the story about era
and age and even
say something about
wayne's aesthetic you know i wanted him
to feel a little bit behind
you know and so no people are not really
doing that that way anymore but he's a
guy who's kind of still holding on
to something a bit there were things
that that
i definitely played with in terms of
voice
voice and speech patterns and even in
the you know because it's three errors
of a life old age is sort of a
no-brainer right like there's things
that they do to make you look
significantly different but i think the
real challenging part was actually in
the two younger ages
was in the
33 and 43 to understand how
your in your experiences
your self-esteem your confidence your
partnerships how all those things affect
the body the mind speech patterns him
being um
demoted and what that does to somebody's
confidence and energy so you go from
being somebody who was like very proud
and in command to someone who was just
like oh you work on a desk and you have
no power in the situation and actually
wayne was
how he perceived it he was demoted to a
secretary right
so what that does to you until you get a
shot again to be another be a cop and so
suddenly he's gonna talk faster and be
excited and be energetic and so all
these things that you have to consider
um that end up giving you real
information about how you play something
you know and
those are things i think about and that
we talked about
the curious case of benjamin button the
curious case benjamin button was crazy
crazy i'd never forget we started
shooting that in 2006 i have so many
stories about that which i we don't have
time i'll never forget
going from working on the 4400 where
they're literally about to kill me off
on that show to flying into la to
audition for david fincher i think i had
to fly in i feel like it was like a
weekend or something and nobody's in the
office except like
david fincher and larae mayfield as
casting director and i'm auditioning by
myself and
going from that moment to two years
later i'm doing a roundtable event with
brad pitt and kate blanchett and taraji
p henson and jared harris and tilda
swinton like a bunch of like incredible
actors and i'm here i am a few years out
of school so that moment
and all that it represented
the process of getting that job
to filming that to being in new orleans
the
there was something that suddenly felt
slower about doing film there was a pace
to it that felt right for my own
creative rhythm like all of it was
absolutely fascinating man one of the
best experiences and just getting to
work with a genius and david fincher and
hearing all the all the stories going in
into it but then having my own
experience and relationship with him
and getting to work with him again a few
years later on
several years later actually in house of
cards
none like it man it was it was terrific
i was willing to turn it down i was
willing to turn it down i read this
wonderful movie i have an opportunity to
play this part tizzy opposite of taraji
p henson she's amazing but
there was sort of a pact i made to not
do
simulated sex scenes like i always
wanted to get to a point where like
listen i wanted to be
successful enough where people still
wanted to work with me even if i had to
have a double or
good enough to where they would be like
okay we can kind of edit that out like i
i've articulated that to friends and
family for over 20 years and so when i
got to that point in
in reading curious case of benjamin
button and being offered the job it was
just unclear to me
what they were doing with that scene and
so i just had to communicate that listen
i i really want to do this job i'll take
it but on one condition that if
if this is a sex scene this isn't isn't
something that i'm comfortable doing it
just has to do with you being able to
live with yourself and everybody's got
their boundaries like whatever they are
like things that are boundaries for me
seem silly to other people right like
totally they're like you're tripping
dude and i respect that you know but we
all have to create our our little
boundaries for
for our own peace of mind
[Music]
swanson
kind of anything i do i'm i'm a little i
could be a little annoying like there's
no doubt like very kind of hands-on and
particular and specific about things and
so in building characters and looking at
stories that it was great to have a
healthy space a necessary space to be
able to communicate these ideas have a
seat at the table and be able to impact
without having to necessarily push that
it was like this is a real position
a real necessary space for you to be
able to engage with
our director ben cleary and the
our producing team
and to make a
a real contribution as far as shaping
how the story is being told not just
like your specific choices and
but like touching on
all aspects of the film you know not and
i'm not at all trying to indicate that
that was more me than anyone else at all
what i'm saying is just to have a space
in there where you get the voice your
opinion
and and have some weight
and it felt it felt natural because i
think i'm
i'm pretty naturally communicative tend
to have a point of view and an opinion
and so for that to be welcomed
was
was really nice and it felt it felt
natural and especially with ben cleary
getting to bounce these ideas off early
on and have
have an impact on the story because the
ideas resonated with them was
was really fulfilling